two preseason meetings two regular season meetings
on the schedule between these
two as Murphy shot that's a
score a little bit to the left but Murphy does a
nice job baiting him and just pulling that stick
in a little bit tighter to change the angle of it
Perry throws it through Seth Jones Bard wants it
shoots it it's blocked away they're cheating over
it to Bard Taylor Hall open Cory Perry is second
of the Night Hawks grabed the lead 3-2 in the
third power play unit you know Cory Perry was left
alone a couple of times as soon as Seth Jones and
Taylor Hall Perry Bard Bard looking for an opening
knocked Away by Hutchinson ha to the puck and it
Glides down to Peter morazzi snaap back to Bard
Red Wings change bard still on the ice but D on an
open net his first goal with the Blackhawks in the
pre-season every goal
counts he got the monkey off his back but his
very first of the preseason and it's going to
be an assist from Peter mirazic all the way in
net and all the way down finally it's Bard who
gets that one in after several attempts on the
empty net 98 gets it done I don't think he's very
happy no I I think he actually was hoping
for a much different first preseason goal